I mean I can start this off but I wanted
first just to open up the floor if
there's someone that has a burning
question that they want to ask okay good
we got one here go ahead I'm impressed
with what we working on getting up to
scientific product they made and
dissolve to you look at you like the new
Frank Lloyd Wright in construction and
structural engineering because he also
started with nuclide design and over
time except you don't use them I see
going at same direction one question I
mean predetermine the Occident of the
building with that material in time so
we built the entire stable making
example that side how do you return a
select yeah that that's it I think okay
I think that's a great question so how
do you how do you determine the
obsolescence or or in other words like
how how do you design the duration of
all these things in the built
environment and I've been thinking about
that exact question
and so one short answer is that I think
it would be interesting and relevant if
architects and designers were able to
specify and were called on to specified
duration just like when they pick a
material now they're called on to
specify the color the finish maybe the
strength the texture but maybe they
should also be specifying the duration
so you could add a 2-year material a
20-year material a 200-year material but
I think of course the question gets that
to one of the things that architects are
typically bad at which is acknowledging
that after the building is built they
don't have control over it so it would
be hard to know
how long the Empire State Building you
know was going to last based on all
kinds of other political factors you
know in real estate prices actors etc so
I think my responses to that we should
be getting more familiar with those
unknowns and maybe designing more
open-ended systems not just designing
for the day the building is done and
photographed but designing for the
possibility that its use will change
over time that it might be taken down
prematurely that it might have to last
longer than expected and maybe there's
some kind of switches to be able to be
built in there this is going to like
take a few dots to connect but like what
Kevin was talking about you know that
you could design in the ability to have
an intervention later that would alter
the course re correct the course I think
would be very fascinating one last note
about this particular material
originally I was thinking of it as
trying to hit a sweet spot between like
on a spectrum of durability and
biodegradability and I thought okay we
just need to find the right spot there
but I realized later as that spot I you
know was very hard to meet that probably
better and what this actual material
does already is as trigger Abal
biodegradability so it's relatively
inert and stable and functional while
it's in its built form but when we want
it to biodegrade we break it up we put
it with other bacteria and worms and
food scraps and that will allow it to
biodegrade very quickly so that kind of
two-step process I think could be really
helpful as well
that's maybe another quick comment on it
it's interesting because we always have
to build for a lifetime
I mean we NASA and you know you do for
an airplane whatever but I just want to
add to the potential for self-repairing
and that's something that we had built
into our designs for the mica texture is
that if you don't actually bake the
bricks if you leave them live that does
allow you the possibility if there's a
crack to have them re-- gross you have a
self-healing
building I think that covers that
question pretty nicely any other
questions for our panel I wanted to I
want to do something that kind of I'm
glad the two of you sitting together
because that's what spurred this
question for me you know with with
Kevin's suggestion of having an changing
our scientific process to have
researchers sort of present their
proposals prior to proceeding with the
actual research research and listening
to Michael's questions of you know do we
really understand the real problem that
we're trying to fix and I wonder how we
can integrate that sort of foresight
into you know a design where we would be
proposing opposing projects and making
sure that the projects are there to
really serve with problems that we need
to solve and your thoughts there I'm
sort of the question that we try to duck
I know we recognize that we have a
tendency to think well we have in a new
technology a hammer and the natural
human response is you around look what
looks like a nail yeah excite we're
biased because we invented the
technology and so on so the best course
the best course of action I think is to
abdicate that responsibility and say we
can do as does anyone want this because
they do not will just walk away not even
bother developing it but you should do
that or you start developing the
technology in the first place because so
then the cost can design it according to
the needs of the actual application but
who are you asking everyone I mean I
mean the cow that you know the and the
you know the Edison worked very hard to
try to get someone to buy in you know
you don't always know what the
applications are and they may turn out
to be very different
that's true but again
early on I think the problem with
technology development recently has been
a loss of public trust due to
inadvisable choice of first applications
by the people who invented it and lack
of coordination among technology
developers and rightly
choosing initial applications so
balanced right who has the right to
decide even among technologies we use
intellectual property for that is it
right for us to use our intellectual
property to say no don't do that because
we think it's dangerous chaos control
and destroy the reputation in the field
for everybody else that's an open
question it's a very interesting one we
have a burning comment maybe here and I
think it's member to let Michael comment
our worker yes Ari is this part of this
yes ok it's the latest this question ok
so one of the things you know I I do
technology development as a medical
engineer has for many years and it's
very difficult when you're developing a
new technology to understand what is
going to be good at what's not you to
get so it's very easy to write a grant
or to write a paper input a schematic
and say like it's gonna do XYZ but part
of the discovery when you develop
technology is as you know that you
expect it to do why but it doesn't does
why crime and that's what it's actually
good at and so one question I have now
with respect to this idea of letting
folks decide is how to get around the
fact you're letting them decide on
figure one on the schematic when any
technologists with a minute that your
schematic has never how does it work and
that's the beauty of the technology
Michael our Kevin's a great point I
think that we have largely been able to
evade that problem because we are
working with CRISPR and if you were
working with almost any other
biotechnology I would say more than one
functional component it's just never
going to work the way you expect it's
just not reliable the system is too
complex and so on but because it's
CRISPR in general we can say look we've
worked a lot with CRISPR it works in all
organisms it works this efficiency it
becomes an engineering problem it's not
it's not a science problem anymore it's
not a what what are the consequences
reactions going to be it will we can do
why well we don't know how long it's
going to take us to do Y but we will be
able to do Y so long as you stay within
that sphere now the harder bit is what
about beyond that but again I'm
interested at least as much in providing
in ensuring that somebody else has
oversight because in a lot of cases the
creative application of Y could be
disastrous oh yeah and and and that's my
overriding concern is that five years
ago even four years ago no one imagined
we would have a technology that might
allow a single person to unilaterally
set in motion a process that would edit
every organism of a target species it
was unimaginable you do not see it in
science fiction anywhere as it turns out
because it is slow detectable and can be
overwritten it's probably not that
dangerous it looks really scary but in
itself it's not scary except to the
damage it could cause to public
perception so it's sort of an ideal test
case to do something different but I
think we need to because the next one
could actually be that dangerous and I
want the people whose job it is to
identify things like that to have as
much lead time as possible intervene up
to and including approaching the people
who proposed it and saying have you
considered this maybe you should not and
this may sit
the idea of pre proposing a
technological concept is limited to
situations where the consequences could
as you right I think very rightly
suggest could be really catastrophic
problem is what is that combination of
conditions how do you and that's why I
think I think about the same time the
rules for engineering complex systems
apply to engineering science as well we
work wire science and engineering to
keep working
we need new technologies merely to stay
where we are we can't exactly stop so it
would be reckless hubris to unilaterally
engineer the entire scientific
enterprise all at once so at the other
point of gene drive is it is our field
trial for other areas of science if it
works well in gene drive I think science
will be faster you're not going to waste
your time going down blind alleys that
other labs have already explored and you
never hear about no you you know who to
collaborate with so I think it will be
better but we need to try it and find
out what's right here if it works when
we can say hey all of you
gain-of-function people building
dangerous viruses in your labs maybe we
should be you should be a little bit
more open to because you have similar
sorts of concerns geoengineering and
then we can expand from there I just
want to do make one make one point sorry
Michael you're never going to get to say
anything you better make it good what it
gives to your turn you know there is I
understand this what you're saying but I
think kind of what Lynne was between you
two and what I think a lot about too is
I mean even with this CRISPR story there
is something to be said to basic science
research that does explore new things
and really that's where CRISPR came from
you know it was looking at bacterial
adapted immunities and some people cared
about a lot of people didn't care about
it and this is you know so I I think it
there is obviously the space for
engineering these systems but science
plays a really important role in shaping
this - and the way where you perform
then so there does you know they're neat
we need to figure out we will do this as
a group figure out where the balance is
there I think in exploring these these
complex issues
problems and I don't I'll step back from
what I wanted you know real problems not
build problems it's just I think I mean
we have two kinds of problems one our
problems that technologies can fix and
another the kinds of problem is the
problem of creating the problems that
technologies have to fix so these kind
of worldview deeper problems and so if
we were actually serious culturally
about addressing both kinds of problems
I don't know you know this is really
simple and naive but if the point is the
point that every dollar we spent on the
first kind of problem we'd spend at
least that much and the other kind of
problem I don't think we spend anything
on what I originally called a
fundamental problem or at least the
other kind of problem so I don't see any
gesture of seriousness at all for one
kind of problem and a lot for the other
kind of problem yeah oh hi now you want
it on this
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
and what's a reciprocity right yeah so
changing that flow and bring up a point
that was brought up yesterday and that
is solving problems not just in the
United States but in places like Africa
and so on and I just want to say from
our own example I've been involved with
developing an arsenic biosensor which
arsenic in the water is a huge problem
in places like Bangladesh and so this
should be a no-brainer developing this
little thing that you dip in it is a
live sport but it's all enclosed our
recommendations that now includes not
just the ability to burn it but Clorox
vented system and so on it's safe as far
as we're concerned so on so you go to
the Bangladesh you can say here's this
great way that you can easily test the
water you get a color output to
determine whether it's arsenic and the
answer is if it's so great how come
you're not using in your country now we
didn't do the major development this is
being driven by people in the UK they
can't even test it in Europe so I've now
called my links at the EPA and we're
trying there's simply not because we
have the problem but so you can then go
back to the Bangladeshis and say no this
is not the evil empire we really are
trying to help you it's licensed for use
in the United States so it all becomes
much more complicated than just going
out there and doing good you know there
there is a level of suspicion and so on
if it's so great why aren't you using it
well that brings up another
real demand for engagement yes you know
yes that
and as a you know but studying the
biomedical field for a long time I see
this also in this way of looking at it
are we treating the system symptoms are
we treating the causes you know and I
think that that is something to keep in
mind and and partly what this technology
allows for is very sophisticated ways of
approaching things and and so can we
start to look at this in different ways
that are more you know caught at the
root of the problem we have we have one
we have time for like one question if
there's anything else out there yes
Chetta mhm
using as a way to think about thank you
that's beautiful I just finished it so
thank you to our speakers who have come
from all over the US to share their
insight perspective I really again want
to thank our sponsors of this event the
Yeltsin super biospheric studies has
been our major backer as well as the
Yale interdisciplinary Center for
Bioethics and the Frankie program in
science and the humanities and I really
also just thank all of you for joining
us today and yesterday of what's been
what I think is a really important
conversation and what I hope is really
just the beginning of something that we
can continue to come together with their
diverse viewpoints and backgrounds and
try and shape this this issue as you can
see there's a lot of work to do and so
enjoy the rest of your day I also wanted
to say you know we're having roundtable
discussions here and with sort of a
smaller group because we obviously have
to be somewhat effective in what we
converse about but in the spirit of
transparency you're welcome to drop in
and observe what we're talking about and
and sit and see what we're trying
to do so the doors the door is open and
secondly all of our talks have been
filmed and will be up on the website at
WWE org as soon as are available so you
can always check back or share this with
people you know that might be interested
so thank you
[Applause]
[Music]